hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut hinter
mir steht mal wieder eine Palette ich
habe euch ja jetzt auch länger gar nicht
mitgenommen auf meiner retourenreise
auch wenn ich halt schon öfter mal was
gemacht habe aber ich dachte mir wir
müssen noch ein bisschen chillen mit
Retouren Content irgendwann reicht's
auch mal aber ich dachte mir heute
könnte es vielleicht interessant werden
hoffen wir es mal das hier sind nämlich
Amazon Retouren wir haben hier sechs
Kisten und das Besondere ist die kommen
nicht aus Deutschland sondern ich habe
die von einem holländischen Händler
gekauft und wir schauen einfach mal ob
das vielleicht ein bisschen was anderes
ist und was neues und ob sich das
natürlich lohnen kann ich würde sagen
wir laber gar nicht lange okay komm wir
machen jetzt erstmal auf
[Musik]
okay ich würde sagen das reicht erstmal
wie man sehen kann das sind sechs Kisten
was mir erstmal direkt auffällt also die
wurden auf jeden Fall schon mal geöffnet
weil die ja eigentlich kann man sich
merken wenn die komplett einmal mit
diesem Amazon Klebeband frisch umhüllt
sind so gesehen sind die direkt von
Amazon und keiner hat mal drüber geguckt
gehe jetzt halt schon aber ich dachte
mir ich bestelle es trotzdem mal ich
weiß an dieser Stelle wirklich nur groß
was drin sein kann und was hat der
Gesamtwert ist ist halt hier jetzt auch
ich sag mal eine Überraschung für mich
habe so ein Händler halt empfohlen
bekommen von einem Kollegen von mir und
dann habe ich da einfach mal so eine
Palette bestellt man kann ungefähr sagen
pro Karton habe ich 250 € bezahlt also
insgesamt 1,5 dann schauen wir mal ob
sich das lohnt aber was ich auch direkt
vorweg sein kann ich werde nur die
beiden oberen Kisten ja aufmachen das
ist mir sonst einfach zu viel Chaos okay
okay ich bin ehrlich erste Eindruck ist
erstmal nicht gut aber die Kiste ist ja
auch ziemlich ah vielleicht haben wir
einen guten Fund oder so aber es ist das
übliche grenzkrams Zeug was ich schon
kenne hier ist glaube ich ein
Saugroboter unten drin fangen wir
einfach mal an das Ding ist halt wenn du
so ein Karton für 250 € bekommst ist das
meiste so FBA Ware das heißt
chinesisches Zeug was in China
produziert wird wie zum Beispiel diese
lockenbürste oder so die kostet würde
ich mal schätzen 25 und 30 € ist aber an
sich gar nicht so schlecht weil sowas
geht halt auch safe weg da ist der Markt
halt super da und davon haben wir gleich
nicht nur eine sondern zwei bzw das hier
ist wahrscheinlich einen Lockenwickler
oder so aber den will ich jetzt gar
nicht aufmachen okay wir können uns
glaube ich drauf einigen dass ich nur
versuche die guten Sachen rauszuziehen
weil die sind halt super viele kleine
Teile drin wie auch hier so ein Kabel
oder so und ja das ist ja irgendwie auch
langweilig trotzdem bin ich mir sicher
aus dieser Kiste wenn ich jetzt 250
bezahlt habe man könnte auf jeden Fall
bestimmt 450 Euro damit verdienen in der
Kamera 30 € ist geil alleine hast
brauchst du sowas für zu Hause sicher
dann kannst du immer wenn bei dir
beeindruckt kannst du gucken bei solchen
Sachen das täuscht manchmal du denkst
dir so irgendein Schrott und dann kostet
das aber 80 € man weiß es nicht das
macht das Ganze eigentlich immer so
spannend also Tobi hinter der Kamera ist
auch so ein neuer Retouren also der hat
gerade dann so das erste Mal glaube ich
Amazon Retouren in echt gesehen das ist
wirklich spannend das ist halt wirklich
so wie früher Fußball spielen bei mir
mein Hobby war heute sind es Retouren
so jetzt schauen wir mal hier was sind
denn hier ah LED zeiling light Power
kann es amtschen gut das ist jetzt
irgendeine Deckenlampe sah eben aus wie
ein Saugroboter da kann man sich auch
manchmal täuschen Lampen sind zwar immer
dann nicht so nice weil es gibt halt
super viele Lampen und die sind dann
übelst günstig so im Retouren Business
weißt du aber die kostet vielleicht neue
50 € und dann kriegst du noch 20 Uhr
wenn du damit gut umgehst Amazon
retourenlager Rücksendezentrum was ist
das denn irgendwas für Kinder kann das
schauen wir mal rein wow guck mal hier
ein Goofy
ach das ist eine Brotbox also das wurde
jetzt wirklich retourniert von dem
Kunden es ist natürlich nicht alles
Retourenware ein Großteil des Retouren
war und vieles ist auch einfach
Überschuss aus irgendwelchen Amazon
Lagern wer schickt denn bitte eine
Brotdose zurück schaut man sich die dann
in echt an und denkt sich nee die passt
doch nicht zu einem Kind aber Goofy
Brotdose es kann sogar sein dass es eine
Marke ist ich kann mich jetzt so mit
Tupperdosen nicht so aus und dann kostet
die halt wirklich 15 Euro
na ja
es tut ein bisschen gerade auch weh also
hier sind super viele Einzelteile drin
also wie gesagt hier haben wir ein Basic
Cube ja das ist nicht nur ein Fidget
Spinner das ist ein Fidget Spinner ich
wusste nicht dass es sowas gibt aber das
nehme ich mir mal mit für zu Hause
also damit man halt immer was zu tun hat
so für die Schule oder so hier kann man
dran drehen dann kann man hier noch ein
Fidget Spinner drehen dann kannst du
hier dann noch Schrauben hier drauf
drücken Alter guck mal das ist Leute die
wirklich ganz krankes ADHS haben ohne
dass jetzt irgendwie böse zu machen und
dann kannst du hier mit dem Schlüssel
immer noch das Schloss auch auf so eine
Idee muss man auch erstmal kommen man
wundert sich oft aber irgendwer kauft es
immer dann haben wir hier noch
Steckdosen ich schau mal kurz nach unten
rein so pass mal auf boah so das könnte
vielleicht interessant sein hier haben
wir jetzt einen Donner Klavier für DJs
Musik Produktion ist das vielleicht
nicht verkehrt was wir zu schätzen wie
teuer 40 € 40 € ist 40 € ist glaube ich
gut ich sage aber es ist noch teurer 146
und ich habe gesehen hier unten sind
noch mehr Sachen drin in diese Richtung
irgendwelche Wachsmalstifte warte mal
nee doch nicht der Schreibtischlampe mit
Ladefunktion kostet wahrscheinlich neue
so ungefähr 35 alles klar dann haben wir
jetzt das meiste das ist auch immer
interessant manchmal sind da ganz coole
Sachen drin aber sonst würde ich sagen
lass mal die Kiste erstmal so beruhen
dass du auf jeden Fall eine Kiste wenn
ich dafür 250 bezahlt habe was ich euch
ja gesagt habe wird sich das lohnen die
Kiste hat sich jetzt gelohnt auch wenn
da keine Kasse Markenware drin war
trotzdem auf jeden Fall absolut in
Ordnung dann würde ich sagen machen wir
hier noch weiter und was auch das Gute
ist dieser FBA Sachen funktionieren alle
also da sind meistens keine Sachen
Defekt
okay Scheiße ähnlich es sieht so aus
guck mal hier haben wir eine Samsung
Fernbedienung 20 Euro es sieht so aus
als wäre hier eigentlich quasi noch mehr
Kleinzeug drin als eben schon dieses
Ding kommt anderswelt
Stellen Alter was ist das kein Plan was
das ist für eine Brille weißt du es ich
glaube das hat so verschiedene
Funktionen mit so Nachtsicht und dann
noch so ein bisschen also ich kann dich
jetzt so unscharf erkennen naja gut
keine Ahnung wofür es ist irgendwas für
Smartphone wahrscheinlich perfekt
kompatibel mit raspberry und Windows 80
€ eigentlich kann man sagen man muss
sich jetzt aus diesem Boxen nur die fünf
besten Sachen raussuchen und hat die 250
€ schon wieder raus und dann hat man
noch ganz viel grinskram Alter
thermal Soli Verdunster pass mal auf und
die Dinger sind auch gerade gefragt so
Leute diese Dinger sollte man nicht
unterschätzen die schauen uns jetzt mal
ein bisschen genauer an wirklich noch
komplett neu eingepackt ich kenne die
Marke zwar nicht sieht auch aus wie eine
PS5 oder das Ding ist irgendwie
neuerdings die Dinger also das kostet
zum Beispiel auch 70 oder 80 nur
Kaufland ich weiß nicht warum die bieten
so viele Sachen einfach so krass günstig
an für 35 na ja okay egal wir machen mal
schnell weiter guck mal ein Headset
diese hätten wir uns früher aber
Headsets gefreut ich habe glaube ich 100
Stück davon mittlerweile also wenn du
ein Headset brauchst sag bescheid ja mal
noch ein Headset das Ding ist der
Headset max ist auch krass überflutet
und es gibt super viele Headsets aber
die Kosten zum Beispiel jetzt so neu 45
€. das Problem ist dass man halt 45 €
dafür lenkt sich bekommt sondern
vielleicht zu 15 okay hier haben wir
noch ein großes ah guck mal das ist auch
immer eigentlich fast immer drin
zumindest bei sonnenkram hier haben wir
einen nackenmassagegerät nächstes Jahr
drin
und dann kannst dich Abend
entspannt hast du schon mal getestet
sowas willst du mal auch nicht meine
ehrliche Meinung zu den Dingern ist
kauft euch die nicht schickt mir hier
noch irgendwas ins Auge was mich umhaut
you dreamer pass auf das könnte
vielleicht noch wertvoll sein und
Plattenspieler
es ist so random manchmal oder für
Musiker ist auch nicht was dabei DJ sie
könnten das Ding jetzt hier mit dem mit
dem Plus Klavier plus Headset plus
Klavier ich sag 120 160 also der von
meinem Papa kostet deutlich mehr na ja
hier sind dann halt super viele
Krimskrams Sachen noch drin professional
gelblich
also ich würde sogar fast sagen die
andere Box ist besser als die hier aber
naja Leute ich würde sagen wenn wir das
jetzt hochrechnen ist die Palette in
Ordnung ist jetzt kein negerding aber
auf jeden Fall akzeptabel wir können
jetzt natürlich noch die ganzen Pakete
auch noch aufmachen ich wollte einmal
testen weil ich dachte vielleicht ist es
ja krass wenn man es jetzt aus dem
anderen Land bestellt aber eigentlich
ist es genau das gleiche wie wenn ich
jetzt von einem deutschen der Taufe naja
Leute das reicht schon auf jeden Fall
jetzt auch erstmal wieder mit Amazon
Retouren wenn ich aber mal wieder krasse
Retouren von Amazon kaufe dann mache ich
natürlich wieder ein Video sonst wenn es
immer nur dieser FBA Krampfes verstehe
ich dass es vielleicht nicht ganz so
spannend ist ich hoffe ihr hattet
trotzdem Spaß beim Zuschauen nächste
Woche geht's wieder auf Reise und ich
habe euch ja auch noch das Deutsche Post
Pakete Video versprochen kommt auf jeden
Fall noch ich habe es noch nicht
geschafft das aufzunehmen aber das
sollte in den nächsten Wochen auf jeden
Fall kommen lassen aber da abonniert den
Kanal und ja wir gucken jetzt Bundesliga
haut rein ciao